I met Diablo Cody the writer of this
film about 12 years ago and when I went
when I met her what I didn't realize at
the time was that I was beginning a
journey I was beginning a journey with a
storytelling partner that is now you
know every five years or so we've made a
movie together and I hope that continues
to happen into the future and with this
movie she gave me a ring and said I have
an idea for a movie and she explained it
in two sentences I said yeah you got to
write that what's hard to believe it's
then it's six weeks later I got the
script and it was a first draft but it
was also a shooting draft Wow
no it's infuriating I mean it took me
seven years to write up in the air I'm a
slow writer she doesn't use treatments
or index cards she just kind of walks
into the woods and finds her way to the
other end
Charlize you also chose to be a producer
on this film so we're really invested in
it why was that Jason and I are just
we're partners in crime so that's how we
started our relationship on young-adult
and we're just continuing telling
stories like this hopefully you know
we'll get to continue to tell more
stories I don't know we just for some
reason we just work really well together
McKenzie I'm wondering how you came to
this role or did it come to you Jason
told me about it I'd wanted to work with
him for a long time I auditioned for him
a long time ago and he was and I was
very like one of a very very early
audition in my life and and he was right
there in the room and like working with
me which normally directors don't do and
at that stage in my career were not in
the audition room with me and like
taking the time to really work through
it and it was such a like lovely just
acting class experience that had nothing
to do with getting the role which I did
not get but then yeah he told me about
this script and even before I read it I
was very much on board and then I read
it and loved it and I love you
adult and the idea of getting to
penetrate that um trifecta sounded and
in Ron what about you I I thought you
had a really difficult task because here
you are playing a character whose job is
to disappear but ya couldn't disappear
right but you can't go anywhere and you
have to at the end of the day it all has
to add up as to how could this guy not
have known and if he didn't know how can
we forgive him for you know not knowing
and can she stay I mean the truth is I
have played a lamp in this movie if you
ask me to play a lamp floor lamp table
lamp I said ever the end table yeah no I
and you guys were all in place I
remember we came and we did the reading
at your house and it was I thought it
was just beautiful
and for Charlize and Jason what was the
parent aspect of this that may have
spoken so strongly to you apart from the
fact that it was such a great script
where obviously we're both parents and I
think on the surface all of that stuff
felt very familiar you think ultimately
what the movie is trying to say this
idea that we go through our lives I
think always questioning if we are doing
what we're supposed to do in that moment
in our life like when we check in with
ourselves like you know nobody's handing
us this life guide book so I think that
idea of like thinking am i growing up
too fast am i growing up too slow
changes when you become a parent and
then all of a sudden you have to really
go oh and now I have to grow up and I
have to make in a room for this child
isn't this new chapter of being a parent
from a parenting point of view the most
important thing to me was that the movie
feel authentic I wanted to see a version
of parenting on screen that I recognized
for myself and parenting is scary and
we're not allowed to talk about that you
know we we're in a moment of time where
we share almost everything about our
lives we share in
our problems what medication we're
taking all kinds of things but we don't
talk about the vulnerability of
parenting we don't talk about what it's
like to be up in the middle of the night
and feel like you don't know what you're
doing you feel sometimes you feel like a
failure sometimes you feel like you
weren't handed that the guide book that
clearly everyone else must have gotten
and and what that must it would it would
have felt like for Tully to arrive at
the door in the mountain in the midst of
all that and let you know that you're
not failing that you're not alone the
humor is obviously embedded in the
script from the beginning but for you
you had the task of making it letting it
not go dark letting it not go sad too
far in either direction I I think
honestly that comes down to casting this
is a joke right
early on in the movie that's an
impossible joke it's so tough and
Charlize does it effortlessly it's you
know she's in the principal's office and
the principal's talking about oh you
look like you're ready to pop and and
this and that and Charlize goes oh yeah
it's a blessing it's a really tricky
line to not overplay your hand and
that's something that all three of them
do brilliantly you never feel as though
they're trying to be so funny as to
separate themselves from reality and
separate themselves from the character
they're playing they are perfectly
willing to play those roles flaws and
all in the most human way and Trust
trust that trust that that will work
Charlize there was the scene where you
were jogging and I was watching you
thinking this is your Jake LaMotta I
mean you had to change your body
completely to do that yeah I mean it was
pretty much a no-brainer when Jason send
me the script I say I don't even know if
we ever really had a conversation about
if I was gonna do this which was a real
bummer too because I just finished
atomic blonde and I was like loving my
body weight to rock a bikini that summer
and then Jason called and he was like
you have a baby on page 10 and yeah I
mean it was just like I went to work we
didn't have a lot of time and so it was
it was really fun for three weeks and
then
it was not so fun wait wait yeah I had
done it once for a film but I was in my
20s late 20s and it was a little
different and this time around I
actually dealt with depression for the
first time just I think eating the
amount of processed food that I was and
the amount of sugar that I was taking in
and so the physical transformation
actually ended up being the emotional
and transformation which I just wasn't I
didn't expect I thought I kind of
compartmentalized them and they ended up
being really the same thing and I was
just lucky to have Jason shoot that and
use that but yeah I was he he almost cut
that scene the jogging scene and I
begged him to shoot it because I knew a
lot of people would think it was
prosthetics and I was like that's like
the one scene where you cannot like
that's all me and I think I don't want
to that from Oscar just for myself I'm
like you just shoot that for me women do
this every day
you know I adopted my kids I didn't go
through pregnancies and women go through
this every day and they're not called
brave and so it's a weird thing to think
of it that way as when people are like
you're so brave if we're doing that I'm
like well you know what women do this
every single day and if I was gonna play
this I wanted to get as close as to
feeling what that felt like or feeling
what Marla was feeling Mackenzie were
the opposite of the character that you
were playing which had a kind of it's
not frenzied but she was so invested in
the moment I mean in a way it is easier
than other types of things cuz it was
also like immediate and it way it didn't
require I don't know they were there I
like how sort of essential she is like
there isn't a lot of forethought she
like feels a pinch and immediately
reacts to that pan she doesn't like
process all of the information then
decide how she's going to manipulate
that information to get something else
that she needs she just is there with
another person and it I've I found it
really warm and nice to play there was a
conversation we had early on about the
second viewing of this film's almost
over your shoulder looking
whereas if you were in your mid-20s and
you could walk into the front door of
the home you're gonna one day live in 15
years from now mm-hmm
what would you be thinking who are my
kids who did I marry what do I do for a
living am I happy how was our marriage
and that's still like yeah makes me feel
so I remember you would remind me of
that every couple of scenes or on a tape
like just remember that you're walking
into your home and this is the first
time you're seeing this whole world and
it's just such a beautiful and intense
thought to have before you do a scene I
really liked that direction
it's I don't know charlize and I are on
the same page ins when neither of us
likes rehearsal so we don't do any of it
I I always believe in the the actors
that would that I cast and I once we do
a table read and I and I feel confident
in the voices at that point I I don't
know I mean what did you guys do I mean
it was there something else that I was
unaware of that behind your back you
mean then maybe I don't know I wouldn't
got fat that's right it mm-hmm
but I think you saw that I played a halo
for about a month
[Laughter]
Mackenzie confession just observing
Charlie's Allah when she didn't think I
was there that worked like that did this
did this quickly the the music I think
was such an important part of this movie
we didn't get a chance to talk about
until now because every piece of music
evokes in your mind it's a trigger for a
memory a place a time and it did
absolutely that was that plan from the
get-go
you know Diablo tends to write a lot of
music into into the script and certainly
that Jayhawk song blue that she and I
both have been fans of and wanted to put
into one of the movies for a while that
being the trigger song that it's you
know it plays it's the song that
Mackenzie plays in the jukebox at the
end it also actually plays in the coffee
shop when violet appears at the very
beginning of the movie it's the first
thing that kind of triggers Marlowe's
character and there's a version of
watching this movie where violet was
never on the coffee shop where the song
comes on and
Marlo imagines the woman choose to date
in her 20s and that's what kind of
starts us on this ride well please don't
reveal the ending to this panel but it
is the end please thank our panel thank
you